bom gente é eu vim aqui pra falar eu
entrei com esse capacete porque
provavelmente é o mesmo capacete que
está nessa imagem que vocês estão vendo
aí era o capacete que o meu pai
utilizava para visitar as obras da
empresa é ele me colocou esse capacete e
com muita honra trago aqui hoje comigo
eu queria dizer para vocês que o meu pai
não é somente meu pai ele é o meu herói
também e é sobre ele que eu vou falar
que hoje é eu sou diretor presidente de
uma empresa de 53 anos que foi fundada
pelo meu pai
essa empresa ela não preciso falar para
vocês qual é a atividade dessa empresa
atividade dessa empresa é de cemitérios
e crematórios serviços funerários e
planos funerários
é isso que nós fazemos
eu também sou presidente do sindicato
dos cemitérios e crematórios privados do
brasil
sou diretor de outras entidades nesse
segmento na faculdade eu fiz faculdade
de comunicação de publicidade e
propaganda
meu nome é zé elias não me levo muito
comum tão zé só tem vários o pessoal
pergunta assim zé quiser então o zé
virou esse aqui
o zé do caixão foi assim que eu sempre
fui conhecido na faculdade
até hoje os meus colegas de faculdade
quando falo de mim é o zé do caixão e eu
sempre dei bem acredito com essas
brincadeiras porque eu entendo que essas
brincadeiras são importantes e
necessárias para as pessoas conseguirem
lidar com o maior medo do ser humano que
é o medo da morte
se vocês pararem para pensar o único
animal que tem consciência da própria
finitude é o ser humano e não é fácil
ter consciência da finitude e menos
fácil ainda é trabalhar com esse
segmento
o nosso segmento não é sexy não é
charmoso
ninguém fica sonhando o dia que o filho
ou a filha vai chegar um almoço de
família ou naquela janta e dizer 'sim
pai mãe eu decidi o que vou sim quero
ser na vida eu quero trabalhar de
funerária eu quero ser agente funerário
quero trabalhar com cremação com os
cemitérios
a gente não sonha isso para os nossos
filhos
mas esse segmento é um segmento pelo
menos é o segmento que eu conheço que
tem mais chance de propósito e de ajudar
as pessoas de todos porque o nosso
trabalho é atender as pessoas no momento
mais difícil da vida delas num momento
de extrema num momento de perda de
alguém que elas amam
vocês devem imaginar eu acho que muitos
aqui já perderam pessoas amadas e
queridas
a gente perde pai a gente perde mãe
marido esposa as pessoas esperem até
filhos não é fácil e não é fácil também
trabalhar com isso
as pessoas falam pra mim assim zé o teu
negócio como qualquer outro
é um negócio como qualquer outro eu falo
não não é e não pode ser no momento que
for nós perdemos o nosso objeto porque
eu não posso comparar um negócio
qualquer
com todo respeito a todos os tipos de
negócio com o que nós fazemos é muito
importante e eu vejo nosso negócio com
uma missão como uma missão e ajudar as
pessoas em ser relevantes na vida das
pessoas em cuidar das famílias que
passam por momentos de perda
todas o meu desejo quando pequeno era de
ser igualzinho meu pai
na verdade pra pra falar a verdade o
desejo não mudou ainda meu desejo é
certa forma sempre foi esse meu pai é o
cemitério trabalhar eu ia pro cemitério
brincar eu ficava lá do ladinho dele
às vezes eu ia nos corredores do
cemitério andava de bicicleta brincava
conhecia até decora algumas lápides de
jazigos
mas o meu compromisso de fato um
compromisso com o legado dele e se eu
considero que o meu compromisso com o
mundo e hoje o compromisso também da
nossa empresa
deixa eu falar também é eu acho que é o
ponto importante é falar sobre a
história do meu pai meu pai teve uma
infância muito difícil
ele perdeu o pai com um ano de idade é
ele não conheceu o pai portanto ele foi
obrigado a mãe dele não conseguia criar
queria que ele não passasse pela
situação de miséria que eles estava o
deu uma família que lhe fosse criado
isso fosse cuidado digamos assim
mas ele não foi cuidadoso foi tratado
como um animalzinho de estimação tipo
mascote humano talvez naquela época
década de 30 as pessoas não tivessem
pets
meu pai era mais ou menos um pet da
família decidiu ea mãe dele decidiu
trazer de volta para viver junto com a
família e começou uma luta muito forte
contra a miséria contra a fome é meu pai
com 78 anos
ele sustentava a família e não era um
sustento ortodoxo como vocês podem
imaginar
meu pai era um faminto comia restos
comia do lixo
caçava a unha como ele falava lagartos
preás ratões-do-banhado vai levar pra
casa pra comer não só para ele comer mas
para toda a família era uma família
muito grande
as minhas avós são irmãs os meus pais
são primos em primeiro grau
minha avó paterna teve dois filhos meu
pai o irmão dele e minha avó materna
teve 17 filhos nem todos eram vivos
nessa época aliás alguns morreram muito
pequenininhos muito criança e por
exemplo meu pai muito pequeno teve que
começar a fazer esse tipo de atividade
então ele pequenininho ele participava é
de uma um abate de porcos na no armazém
local em dona francisca e como
recompensa isso ele recebia um saco com
ossos desses porcos abatidos e esse saco
sempre esses ossos sempre um pouquinho
de cabo e neles
esses ossos eram levados para casa era
feito um cozido e era dividido entre a
família e e as pessoas comiam esses
ossos roíam esses ossos é com carne
pouquinho de cada todas as pessoas iam
os mesmos ossos
primeiro os mais velhos depois dos mais
novos a salvação do meu pai se deu
através do trabalho
ele foi vendedor de jornais de bilhetes
de loteria
ele foi engraxate carregador de malas
isso idade bem pequena
eu tô falando de 7 8 9 10 11 anos já
rico
ele foi óptima empacotador vendedor
viajante
o carteiro corretor de imóveis e
finalmente empresário
tudo isso aconteceu antes dos 30 anos de
idade
meu pai falava ele falava assim pra mim
filho passa eu falo que passei fome
porque eu não faço mais porque se eu
continuasse passando eu queria muito ver
muita vergonha de falar que passei fome
eu quero dizer a vocês que hoje aqui
neste país
milhões de pessoas estão passando fome
neste momento milhares de pessoas nessas
cidades estão passando fome
não importa se elas estão ao alcance dos
nossos olhos ou não porque o fato ela
estará longe dos nossos olhos
só nos ajuda mas a ela não ajuda nada
existe uma certa semelhança no
sofrimento do luto e da perda e no
sofrimento de quem passa fome
são situações extremas de desespero de
impotência falta de perspectiva
eu pergunto a vocês o que é um problema
para quem passa fome
o que que é um problema para quem come
do lixo para quem come restos o que é um
problema para quem perde o pai a mãe ou
para quem perde um filho
na verdade é o nosso grande desafio de
se colocar no lugar do outro
é essa semana em porto alegre choveu a
semana inteira muitos de nós reclamamos
da chuva
reclamamos que as pistas estavam
alagadas que nós estávamos demorando
para chegar no trabalho
a gente reclamou da chuva provavelmente
ao abrigo do nosso lar e dentro do nosso
carro
talvez até no ar condicionado
pergunto a vocês o que é viver uma
semana dessas pra quem não tem lá
pra quem tem que andar a pé
na verdade e eu perguntava para o meu
pai como é que ele conseguia ser pai se
ele não tinha tido um pai e ele me dizia
eu tento seu pai que eu gostaria de ter
tido quando eu tinha 10 anos
eu não fui foi comprar uma bicicleta pra
mim ele naquele momento já não tinha
nenhum problema financeiro pelo
contrário tinha uma vida muito próximo
o melhor que a gente saiu da zona sul de
onde a gente morava até aqui pertinho em
canoas porque havia uma promoção de
bicicletas no lugar aqui enganoso mais
ou menos uma hora a gente andou de carro
foi num sábado de noite desde o momento
que a gente saiu de casa até o momento
de chegar lá
o meu pai foi me dizendo por que que eu
havia merecido aquela bicicleta porque
eu tinha feito jus aquele aquele
presente a bicicleta com o custou 42 mil
cruzeiros
eu nunca vou me esquecer porque chegando
lá já estava quase arrependido de ganhar
bicicleta mas foi algo muito importante
que ele fez pra mim me mostrar que as
coisas não são adquiridas por acaso que
a gente tem que merecer um outro
episódio uma vez eu ele deu o dinheiro
alguém na sinaleira e eu fiz uma crítica
isso eu falei eu fiz um comentário tipo
puxa vida mais ou menos assim pessoa
está pedindo aqui podia estar
trabalhando porque está fazendo alguma
coisa que eu acho que é um comentário
que muitos fazem o meu pai
na hora ele me olhou e ele com muito
jeito ele falou filho é muito mais
difícil do que poder da é ter de pedir
e naquele momento eu senti como eu havia
sido de dico porque a gente fazer
comentários de coisas que a gente não
viveu
é algo me j
a gente tem muito cuidado com isso
naquele momento eu fui idiota eo meu pai
não me melhor por eu ter sido um idiota
mas me deu mais um ensinamento
bom gente o meu pai ele se transformou
num empresário como eu falei é nós somos
pioneiros na nossa empresa em planos
habitacionais em cemitérios verticais em
concreto armado em crematórios privados
aqui no brasil é mas acho que o grande
legado da nossa empresa não é o que ela
faz o que ela fez de material é a ética
eo respeito com que ela se porta é isso
que a gente mostra a todos que trabalham
nesse projeto chamado o nosso grupo que
a gente quer fazer o bem ea gente quer
respeitar as pessoas
o meu pai é em 2004 e voltou a estudar
desde o eja de 1ª a 4ª série do ensino
fundamental 5ª a 8ª conta da adição de
subtração depois segundo grau fez aulas
particulares sábados domingos de noite
porque ele trabalhava o dia inteiro e
finalmente se formou na faculdade aos 76
anos
já numa situação de saúde bastante
debilitada
eu quero dizer a vocês que existem
muitas histórias parecidas com a do meu
pai é vocês devem conhecer várias
superação de realidades superação e de
enfrentamento à realidade adversas
eu acho que o grande mérito dele foi
utiliza utilizar tragédia da fome da
miséria não como pá para cavar um buraco
e se enterrar assim como impulso como
plataforma para ele poder em frente
crescer
eu queria encerrar fazendo duas
reflexões aqui com vocês
a primeira é a seguinte a nossa
realidade ela só existe a partir disso
aqui
a partir dos olhos que enxergam não
existe realidade que não seja aqui a
gente vê através dos nossos olhos
através dos olhos de cada um
então enquanto alguns vêem um problema
algum em transponível outros vêem uma
oportunidade os nossos olhos são os
nossos mestres
se a gente quer realmente mudar o mundo
ou a nossa própria realidade é muito
mais fácil a gente mudar o nosso olhar
antes de qualquer coisa o segundo ponto
eu queria colocar pra vocês é que eu
disse no início do meu pai era meu herói
ele é ele sempre vai ser o meu herói
mas essa é uma homenagem aos heróis e
heroínas da vida de cada um de vocês e
de cada um de nós
nós todos temos os nossos heróis as
nossas heroínas as pessoas que pra gente
representam legados exemplos de força de
superação de ética e essas para essas
pessoas para essa classe de pessoas à
morte é apenas uma morte física
a morte não é real essas pessoas elas se
tornam eternas e persistem em cada um de
nós
elas chegam a debochada morte a morte é
uma realidade relativa a essas pessoas
então a gente tem que perguntar se os
nossos heróis morrem de verdade eu acho
que não
eu tive muita alegria hoje de ter estado
aqui com vocês foi um privilégio e uma
honra muito obrigado